Dies ist die Geschichte
vom Renggbach und seinem Bachmeister.
Seit über 200 Jahren
schauen Mitglieder der Familie Haas
zu diesem wilden Bach
am Abhang des Pilatus.
Und die Menschen
am Fusse dieses Berges
können dankbar sein
für deren Aufmerksamkeit.
Der Grund, wieso man besonders gut
zu diesen Bächen hier schaut,
sind die Stadt Luzern
und Kriens, Horw, Littau.
Das Wasser ist vom Pilatus
sehr schnell im Tal.
Läuft das nicht richtig,
gibt's Probleme in der Stadt -
die will niemand.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Werner Haas, der Bachmeister,
ist zusammen mit seiner Frau Priska
unterwegs nach oben,
Richtung Pilatus.
Jetzt fahren wir
zur Quelle des Renggbachs.
Hier oben beginnt er.
Wir sind fast in der Fräkmüntegg.
Dort, gleich unterhalb der Felsen,
wo der Renggbach noch jung ist,
wollen sie heute
ihren Kontrollgang beginnen.
Wir beginnen zuoberst.
Dann gehen wir den Bach runter.
Unten vereint er sich
mit dem Banzenlochbach.
Danach heisst er Oberer Krienbach.
Wir gehen nicht auf Wanderwegen -
wir müssen unbedingt
dem Bachlauf folgen,
damit wir die Sperren
kontrollieren können.
Da gibt es meist keinen Wanderweg.
Halte dich nicht an einem dürren Ast
fest, damit du nicht abstürzt.
Der Renggbach
ist ein heimtückisches Gewässer,
weshalb man
keinen Aufwand gescheut hat,
seine Zerstörungskraft einzudämmen.
700 Bachverbauungen
sollen den Wildbach zähmen -
und Bachmeister Werner Haas
kontrolliert jedes Jahr,
ob all die Bauwerke
noch funktionstüchtig sind.
Es gibt schon Bachabschnitte,
die wirklich heikel sind.
Man kann nicht überall
dem Bach folgen,
manchmal muss man von oben gesehen
zur letzten Sperre gehen
und das Gelände umgehen, um einen
Felsen rum und von unten wieder ran.
Denn es kann schlicht zu gefährlich
sein, dem Bach zu folgen,
weil Wasserfälle dazwischen sind.
Es sind anstrengende Kontrollgänge,
meist in unwegsamem, steilem Gelände.
Schau, wieder diese Mücken.
Hier ist wieder eine kaputte.
Dann komme ich trotzdem.
Nummer 12.
Das Leitwerk auf der Seite ist
unterspült, es fehlen einige Steine.
Das können wir ergänzen. Die Zwölf.
- Zwölf.
"Leitwerk links", oder?
- Gut.
Es sind nicht grosse Schäden,
aber wenn man es gleich macht,
kostet es auch nicht so viel.
Der Bachmeister und seine Frau
leisten hier
eine beschwerliche Arbeit,
damit die Menschen unten im Tal,
in Kriens und Luzern,
auch bei einem schweren Pilatus-
gewitter ruhig schlafen können.
In einem Jahr ohne Gewitter
denkt man:
"Wieso verbaut man im Wald
Tausende Kubik Beton?"
Und da sieht man: Ohne Gewitter
ist das nur ein Rinnsal.
Aber das ist eben ein Wildbach,
kein Fluss.
Bei einem Gewitter kann er
innert 1 Std. um 1-1,5 m ansteigen.
Nicht wie bei einem Fluss,
bei dem man weiss:
Er hat in zwei Tagen viel Wasser,
da fünf Tage schlechtes Wetter war.
Der bringt schnell viel Wasser
und schnell wieder nichts.
Deshalb muss man die Verbauungen
auf einen Höchststand ausrichten.
Vor wenigen Wochen
entdeckte Werner Haas
im Uferbereich des Renggbaches Risse.
Das Gelände
begann langsam zu kippen.
Es marschiert langsam zum Bach hin.
Wer weiss ...
was mit dem Hang noch geht.
Der Bachmeister wird den Berg hier
im Auge behalten müssen.
Ein Problemhang oberhalb der Strasse:
Beim schweren Unwetter im Jahr 2014
rutschte der Berg talwärts,
Richtung Renggbach.
Der Geologe Beat Keller
besichtigt mit einem Mitarbeiter
die umfangreichen
Sicherungsmassnahmen,
die danach notwendig wurden.
Wir haben Steinschlag
aus der Moräne.
Und wir haben
eine Rutschung des Moränenmaterials.
Wenn es lange regnet, wird es
flüssig und rutscht den Hang runter.
Gelangt es ins Bachbett
und sorgt für Rückstau,
haben wir definitiv ein Problem.
Dann haben wir erst
etwas weniger Wasser.
Und wenn dann ein Damm bricht,
geht's los.
Noch gewaltiger
wütete der Renggbach im Jahre 1738,
eine eigentliche Katastrophe war's.
Auf der Holzbrücke zeigt der Geologe
die damalige Abflusshöhe
des Renggbachs.
10,50 m.
Und gut 11 m kam der Bach,
also bis hier.
Das stelle man sich mal vor -
bis hier oben stand das Wasser.
Das ist gewaltig.
Das kann man sich kaum vorstellen,
wenn man diesen kleinen Bach sieht.
Das sind Moränenblöcke, Findlinge.
Daran sieht man, welch gewaltige
Schleppkraft er entwickeln kann.
Die schleppt er mit.
Luzern und der Pilatus
mit seinen wilden Bächen -
eine Nachbarschaft,
die sich im Jahre 1738
zur Katastrophe auswuchs.
Eine unscheinbare Tafel
erinnert in der Luzerner Innenstadt
an die damalige Überschwemmung.
Rund 1,60 m hoch stand das Wasser,
die halbe Stadt war überflutet,
Kirchen und Plätze im Stadtzentrum um
den heutigen Bahnhof waren betroffen.
Der Renggbach
in seinem begradigten Unterlauf -
es ist die eigentlich Problemzone
dieses Wildbachs.
Beim Unwetter im Jahr 2014
wurden hier grosse Stücke
der Uferverbauung weggerissen.
Hier siehst du:
Hier wollte er durch.
Immerhin:
Die Schutzbauten hielten stand,
ein Überlaufen Richtung Luzern
konnte verhindert werden.
Das Problem wird sein, wenn wir ein
100-300-jährliches Ereignis haben
und der Bach reagiert.
Denn diese Reparatur ist aus 2014.
Da hatten wir
ein 60-70-jährliches Ereignis.
Da versuchte der Bach,
sich rauszufressen
und ins alte Bachbett
Richtung Luzern runterzugehen.
Der Pilatus, den Alpen vorgelagert,
bildet für anrollende Gewitterfronten
eine fatale Barriere.
Das Problem dieses Bachs ist,
dass sein Einzugsgebiet
am Fuss des Pilatus liegt -
eine Nordabdachung.
Da werden alle Niederschläge
und Gewitter zurückgestaut.
Da gibt es mehr als doppelt so viel
Niederschlag wie in Luzern.
Unweit von hier,
hinter einem Waldstreifen,
liegt der Hof der Familie Haas,
der Bachmeisterfamilie.
Seit 1679 lebt und arbeitet die
Familie Haas auf dem Längacherhof,
etwas oberhalb von Kriens.
Seit 200 Jahren
schauen Mitglieder dieser Familie
zum Renggbach,
zu diesem unheimlichen Nachbarn,
der hier zwar unsichtbar bleibt,
doch dessen Grollen
bei einem Gewitter
bis hierher zu vernehmen ist.
Wir spüren ihn bei einem Gewitter.
Dann hören wir Rauschen
oder wie die Steine rollen.
Im Gebiet, durch das der Bach
fliesst, haben wir auch Land.
Da sehen wir ihn täglich
beim Vorbeifahren.
Da schauen wir in den Bach
und seine Zuflüsse.
Wenn es ein richtiges Gewitter gibt
und man die Steine hört,
ist das eindrücklich.
Wenn wir es bis hier hören,
war es heftig.
Er ist 500 m weg von hier,
aber man hört es gut.
35 Jahre lang
hatte zuvor Werner Haas senior
den Bach im Auge behalten.
Es ist immer eine Gefahr:
Du kannst auf einem Ast ausrutschen
und das Bein brechen.
Dann kann es sein, dass die nächsten
zehn Tage niemand vorbeikommt.
Zehn Tage ist vielleicht etwas viel,
aber einige Tage sicher.
Dass man im Wald oder beim Bach
liegen bleibt?
Ja, an einigen Orten
ist es gefährlich, nicht?
Es gibt viele Stellen am Fluss,
an denen das ganze Jahr
niemand vorbeikommt.
Vielleicht Wildtiere -
von ihnen sieht man Spuren.
Das ist schon so.
Man sollte nicht allein gehen.
Bei der ersten Kontrolle,
wenn man nie mitgegangen war,
ist es z.T. eine Wundertüte -
was überhaupt auftaucht: Schluchten
oder Orte, wo man nicht durchkommt.
Da muss man abtasten, wie gut es
hält, die Stellen grosszügig umgehen
und von einer anderen Seite
zurückkommen.
Der Vater ist jeweils
mit Leidenschaft losgezogen,
all die Jahre, dem Bach entlang.
Nur ungern hat er das Amt
altershalber aufgegeben.
Wenigstens ist das Bachmeisteramt
in der Familie geblieben.
Der Sohn
fährt heute allein bergwärts.
Der Kontrollgang
wird ihn an diesem Tag
nicht in gefährliches Gelände führen.
Auf dieser Strecke
lag 2014 schon Geröll.
Die Bäche, die seitlich aus
den Tälern kommen, überschwemmten.
Hier war alles voll Geröll.
Während einiger Tage
konnten wir nicht mehr hoch.
Jetzt gehen wir hier raus.
Dieser Bach ist ganz speziell.
Er heisst Schuhmacher-Graben.
Er bringt praktisch kein Wasser
übers Jahr.
364 Tage ist er trocken,
es kommt kein Tropfen.
Beim Unwetter 2014 -
hier sehen wir das Geschiebe -
hat er einige Kubik Material
runtergebracht.
Man glaubt kaum, dass er so viel
bewegen kann, da er sonst nie läuft.
Jedes Jahr ist der Bachmeister
rund 50 Std. unterwegs am Berg,
dann, wenn es die Arbeit
auf dem Hof zulässt.
Beim Zusammenfluss von zwei Bächen
entdeckt Werner Haas
Schäden in der Ufermauer.
Diese droht einzustürzen.
Diese Fugen sind nicht mehr gut.
Die Ecke wurde
schon 5-6 cm nach vorne gedrückt.
Hier kommt der Renggbach
mit viel Wasser runter.
Was passiert? Die Ecke stürzt ein.
Von oben kommt Druck und die Sperren
stürzen eine nach der anderen ein,
weil es unten nicht mehr hält.
Diese Ecke
muss man also sofort reparieren.
Ganz zuoberst hat man besonders
viel Beton in den Bachlauf gepackt.
Brachial
erscheint hier das Menschenwerk,
doch offenbar muss es so sein.
Weiter oben sehen wir den Pilatus.
Das Gelände ist felsig, sehr steil.
Bei einem Gewitter sind
die Wassermassen sehr schnell unten.
Wenn man den Bach
nicht schon oben verbauen würde,
damit die seitlichen Ufer
stehen bleiben,
würden drastische Schäden
im Tal entstehen.
Das Geschiebe
würde bis nach unten gehen.
Die Brücken wären stark gefährdet.
Zudem wäre viel schneller
alles überschwemmt.
Das summiert sich -
wenn man oben nicht verbaut,
kriegt man unten Probleme.
Man merkte schnell:
Nur unten verbauen bringt nichts.
Man muss schauen,
dass das oben bleibt.
Unterhalb der Pilatusfelsen:
die Alp Bonern.
Bei schönem Wetter
ein beliebtes Wandergebiet.
1'350 m ü.M.
erhaben über dem Mittelland.
Hier beginnt der Renggbach
als harmloses, plätscherndes Rinnsal.
Wie verwunschen
wirkt das bewaldete Quellgebiet.
Auf seinem Weg nach unten
versammelt der Renggbach von links
und rechts noch weitere 30 Gewässer.
11 km2 gross ist sein Einzugsgebiet.
Ein ganzes Bachsystem,
das seit Jahrhunderten
den Menschen Sorgen bereitet.
Nachdem sich der Renggbach durch
das schmale Renggloch gezwängt hat,
ergiesst sich das Wasser
in die Kleine Emme,
die das Entlebuch entwässert.
Auch dies ein Fluss,
der ein beträchtliches
Zerstörungspotenzial hat.
Im Jahr 2005
war es wieder einmal so weit:
Die Kleine Emme
überschwemmte den ganzen Talboden.
900 Menschen mussten damals
entlang des Flusses evakuiert werden.
Die Schäden
beliefen sich auf 180 Mio. Fr.
(Mann) Es geht immer mehr.
An den Wänden
im Hergiswiler Ingenieurbüro
hängen Fotos vom Unwetter 2014,
als der Renggbach über die Ufer trat
und Stücke aus der Ufermauer riss.
In der Sprache der Fachleute
ein 70-jähriges Ereignis.
Peter Scheiwiller
ist mit seinen Kollegen
der Ingenieursfirma Schubiger
zuständig für die Zähmung von
100 Wildbächen in der Zentralschweiz,
darunter auch der Renggbach,
der mit 700 Sperren ganz besonders
in Schach gehalten wird.
Ein Restrisiko bleibt.
Es kann immer wieder
zu Ereignissen ...
Auch beim Renggbach
kann es zu Schäden kommen.
Da sind wir
auch nicht ganz gewappnet.
Das ist halt so.
Damit muss die Gesellschaft leben.
Was ein 300-jähriges Ereignis im Fall
des Renggbaches bedeuten könnte,
zeigt die Karte:
Halb Luzern würde überschwemmt.
Das Schadenpotenzial des Renggbachs
ist enorm,
wenn man
die Siedlungsstruktur anschaut.
Entsprechend ist das Augenmerk
sehr stark auf dem Renggbach.
Denn er hat ein riesiges Potenzial.
Die Menschen im Siedlungsraum, die
Luzerner, haben keine Ahnung davon.
Ja.
Es ist natürlich ...
Eine Ahnung haben sie schon.
Gefahrenkarten
sind im Internet ersichtlich.
Dort wäre es abgebildet.
Aber mir ist klar, dass es nicht
im grossen Rahmen kommuniziert wird.
Im Dorschneigraben,
einem Zufluss des Renggbaches,
stecken Arbeiter im Schlamm.
Ingenieur Peter Scheiwiller
überwacht hier Reparaturarbeiten.
Eine Schadensmeldung des Bachmeisters
hat zu diesen veranlasst.
Aber ... Schaust du noch
wegen der Bepflanzung?
V.a. diese Seitenborde -
du weisst schon.
Was sollen wir ...
- Erle.
Denkst du, Erle?
- Ja, die kommt gerade.
Die Holzsperren wurden bereits
beim Unwetter 2014 beschädigt.
Jetzt müssen sie ersetzt werden.
20, 30 Jahre
sollten sie dann wieder halten.
Die Arbeiten werden vorangetrieben,
denn in den kommenden Tagen
ist mit schlechtem Wetter zu rechnen.
Eine Schwierigkeit
ist immer das Wetter.
Jetzt haben wir super Wetter.
Aber wenn es regnet,
gibt es mit dieser Erde hier
eine verdammte Sauerei.
Das ist die grösste Schwierigkeit.
Es ist Ende Oktober,
ein ruhiger Sommer war's
für den Bachmeister.
Die gefürchteten Gewitter,
die den Renggbach
so schnell anschwellen lassen,
sind dieses Jahr
über den Pilatus hinweggezogen.
Hier hat es
solche Schneisen rausgerissen.
Und doch macht der Berg
Werner Haas einige Sorgen,
denn er rutscht in grossen Schüben
Richtung Bach.
Jetzt können wir schauen.
Das ist die Verschiebung
vom letzten Herbst bis jetzt.
Das sind ca. 3,25 m.
Um so viel wurde es verschoben.
Ganze Baumgruppen stehen schief.
Auf einer Fläche
von zehn Fussballfeldern
ist der Wald in Bewegung geraten.
Die Ursache: Zu viel Wasser im Boden
lässt den Hang abgleiten.
Überall ist die Erde aufgerissen.
Und immer mehr lastet der Berg
auch auf den Bachsperren.
Das sind rund 3,70 m, um
die der Flügel runtergerutscht ist.
Hier sieht man eindrücklich,
wie die Schiene zerrissen wurde.
Sie war hier hinten.
Durch den Druck wurden sie
und die Armierungseisen zerrissen.
Dabei waren die Sperren gut armiert.
Man sieht: Alle Eisen sind entzwei.
Es ist eine Frage der Zeit,
bis dieser Flügel ganz überstürzt.
Und so wird Bachmeister Werner Haas
in den nächsten Monaten
immer wieder hochsteigen,
um festzustellen,
wie brenzlig die Lage ist,
damit die Menschen
am Fusse des Pilatus
keine böse Überraschung
erleben müssen.
* Donnergrollen *
Unweit vom Renggbach
stürzt der Giessbach talwärts.
Auch dies ein Wildbach am Pilatus.
Gegen dessen zerstörerische Kraft
kämpft seit Jahrzehnten
der Bauer Peter Ott,
denn der Bach reisst immer wieder
Stücke von seinem Land weg.
Das wäre alles mein Land.
Das ist jetzt ... schon weg.
Es ist ein einsamer Kampf
und überdies ein verbotener,
sagen die Behörden,
weshalb sie den eigenwilligen Mann
schon dreimal ins Gefängnis steckten,
wie damals im Jahr 1995.
Nach acht Tagen
im Luzerner Zentralgefängnis
kam Peter Ott wieder frei.
Im Gefängnis hatte ich alles,
was ich zu Hause nicht habe.
Ich konnte fernsehen,
Radio hören, Zeitung lesen ...
... duschen, rasieren ...
Also ... wie in einem Hotel.
Zwölf Bagger hat die Polizei
in all den Jahren
bei Bauer Ott beschlagnahmt.
Doch Peter Ott kämpft weiter,
schreibt Eingabe um Eingabe,
wehrt sich mit unermüdlicher
Hartnäckigkeit für eine Sache,
die er als gerecht betrachtet.
Ich kämpfe nicht für mehr Macht
und um etwas zu erobern.
Ich will aber zu dem schauen,
das mir gehört.
Ich will, dass es mir gehört.